barkat grande maria a surtout bagarre à
ça parce que c'est une insulte piège
sans chasse à l'arc et limiter le
rendement des grandes marques est parce
que c c c c'est l'apologie du cinéma et
ça fait du bien
le métro d'art car ça dépend des heures
plus tôt d'arkéa très pratique les
années 90 et 80 rames sera tournoi je
déteste la musique et cette période sa
frappe
je suis pas tellement une série télé
réalité personnellement alors je dirais
d'arca mais je suis marseillaise donc je
suis de perdre atx est mitigé un mix
entre dark et intra d'astral mabala sera
une bonne base sera datera mitigé marqué
les épinards et que quand on est enfant
on dit que s'ils me rattrape énorme
l'arc à dar k à 3020 mineurs